hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast signatures of protective
natural killer cell responses presented
by Michelle Poland PhD and Catherine
bliss md PhD we are excited to bring you
this educational web seminars presented
by labyrinth and sponsored by fluidyne
fluidised develops manufactures and
markets life science analytical and
preparatory systems for single cell
biology and projection genomics the
company's systems based on proprietary
microfluidics and multi parameter mask
cytometry technology are designed to
significantly simplify experimental work
flow increase throughput and reduce
costs while providing excellent data
quality its products are for research
use only and not for you some
Diagnostics procedures to learn more
about fluidyne please visit www
moderator for today's event before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
that this inoculant is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located in the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen will answer as many questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation also please notice that you
will be viewing the presentation in the
slide window to enlarge the window just
click on the screen icon located on the
lower rape finally if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right of the presentation window
or use the Q&A button to let us know
that you're having a problem thank you
now I'd like to introduce doctors Poulin
and lish dr. Poulin is a field
application scientist at fluidyne she
earned a PhD in immunology after
completing a postdoctoral fellowship at
national jewish health dr. poulin joined
BD biosciences as an instructor in the
customer education department she joined
CBS Sciences in 2012 as a field
application scientist and became manager
of the North American field application
scientist team shortly after DBS was
acquired by fluid I'm in 2014 dr. Blish
as an assistant professor in the
department of medicine and immunology at
the stanford university school of
medicine and assistant director of the
Stanford medical scientist training
program she received an MD and a PhD in
immunology doctor Bliss's current
research aims to understand the
successes and failures of the immune
system and to better harness it to
prevent infections coladas perhaps best
known for redefining our understanding
of the diversity of human NK cells a
critical first line of defense against
viruses and tumors she has received many
prestigious awards for research and
mentoring and was elected as a member of
the American Society for Clinical
Investigation the speaker complete BIOS
are found on lab words website please
join me in welcoming dr. Poulin I will
now turn the presentation over to her
good morning I'm Michelle Poulin I'm a
field application scientist with
fluidyne and I'm going to take the first
few minutes of this hour to give you an
introduction to mass cytometry before
dr. blish discusses her exciting
research using mass cytometry in the
field of natural killer cells as we all
know biology is inherently heterogeneous
it consists of biological systems and
biological systems consist of
heterogeneous cell types and these cell
types have diverse functions and
functional states to really be able to
address the complexity in this system
these systems we need high dimensional
proteomics panels that can
simultaneously address not only a
breadth of cell types but also their
depth of function all at the single-cell
now cytometry allows you to look at more
than 50 parameters and millions of cells
the helios our current mass cytometry
system is our third generation mouse
saitama tur and it enables not only the
discovery of new biology but also the
ability to do comprehensive functional
profiling mass cytometry has been used
in a range of research areas but just
for a few examples it's currently being
used in basic research as well as drug
discovery and clinical research to give
you a brief overview of mass cytometry
I'd like to talk in a little bit more
detail about what we call the five
elements of mass cytometry first our
metals these metals as our probes and
reason for this is we get minimal
background which eliminates or minimizes
and in some cases eliminate signal
overlap and also there is no endogenous
cell background from these metals
because they do not occur in biological
systems we currently have more than 50
high purity metal isotope tags available
within a reagent catalog with these
metals we conjugate them to our
antibodies and with those antibodies we
can build high dimensional panels
currently we have more than 600 pre
conjugated antibodies in our catalog
with specificities to both human and
mouse enabling both phenotyping and
functional applications these antibodies
can be purchased individually or as part
of panel kits that I'll talk more about
in the next slide the also sell antibody
conjugation kit
that allows you to label your antibody
of interest with your medal of choice we
offer 35 lanthanide medals but within
these conjugation kits if you don't wish
to do the antibody conjugation yourself
we also offer a custom conjugation
service in addition to antibody reagents
we also sell additional metal conjugated
reagents one example is bar coding
others include cisplatin which is a
viability indicator and intercalate errs
that allow you to identify single-cell
events as well as IDU which allows
assessment of s-phase in addition to
individual antibodies we also offer 18
antibody by panel kits for profiling of
human and mouse systems these panels are
available with up to 17 antibodies pre
optimized as well as all the reagents
and validated protocol for you to stay
in your cells these panels can be used
in combination with one another or as
the backbone to up create your own
custom panel as an example I like to
show you how we combine two panels with
other reagents to build a
high-dimensional panel first we can
start with the human peripheral blood
phenotyping kit that has 17 markers
combine this with our human cytokine kit
which has 11 antibodies bring us up
already to 28 markers and there are an
additional nine open channels where you
can customize additional antibody
markers we can include bar coding DNA
percolators s-phase by bill
the markers or normalization beads as
well as a few environmental monitoring
Channel this brings us up to a total of
fifty four channels and leaves 81 open
so this means that as we expand our
reagent catalog these reagents will be
able to be seen by the existing hardware
of the Helios once the panel has been
established cells are stained with the
panel the cells are introduced into the
Helios or they are ionized in the
high-energy plasma the Helios ionizes
each cell and then uses time-of-flight
technology to focus these isotope tags
into discrete bands that are then
resolved with one Dalton resolution by
the single detector on the instrument
the Helios has a mass range of 135
channels from 75 dolphins to 209
dolphins and as I mentioned before this
allows us to measure all our existing
metal tags and any reagents that we
develop in the future finally gain data
from the single cell samples this is
multiparametric data for large number of
cells per sample and this enables d
profiling of a breath of cell types all
in a single tube and finally I just
wanted to show the ramp in mass
cytometry publications from our earliest
customer to the almost to the present at
this point we're probably getting close
to a hundred and sixty publications
using math cytometry and I would also
note that many of these publications
have been in top-tier journals really
indicating that mass cytometry enables
breakthrough research
thank you very much for your attention
um but I think I'm alive and I'll just
introduce myself on Katherine blush I'm
an assistant professor in the department
of medicine and infectious diseases as
well as in immunology at Stanford and
I'm going to talk today about some work
we've been doing to evaluate signatures
of protected natural killer cell
responses and I want to begin with just
an overview as one we're even interested
in natural killer cells and really I'm
interested in natural killer cells
because they are fast acting in eight
lymphocytes and their specialized for
killing virus-infected malignant or
stressed cells so what we're looking at
in that image is this yellow natural
killer cell reaching around sensing and
getting ready to kill that in orange
tumor cell and that launched it can do
that within minutes and in fact move on
to kill another cell and this occurs for
both virus and to metod cells in
addition they're perceived classically
as a homogeneous population of cells
with static functions but recent data is
really highlighted the fact that that is
an oversimplification but as a result
they've been fairly poorly characterized
in humans so we really felt that a new
understanding of these cells would be
more helpful and to put this in
framework I wanted to provide a bit of
an introduction as to how in k cells are
specialized for killing these virus
infected and malignant cells in really
its I'm going to remember that natural
killer cells function is controlled by a
balance of activating inhibitory signals
such that under homeostatic or tolerant
conditions we have a target cell and
that target cell expresses on its
surface both activating ligands which
are induced under the setting of stress
or infection as well as MHC class 1
molecules that are found on every cell
in your body the encasing turn has
activating receptors which of course are
specific for those activating loggins as
well as inhibitory receptors and these
inhibitory receptors are specific for
the MHC class 1 molecules and basically
provide a pack offer an all clear signal
to tell that NK cell to bugger off and
not attack such that under normal
static conditions that inhibitory signal
wins over the activating signal and the
NK cell stays quiet now there are
several activation scenarios the first
which commonly occurs in the setting of
viruses that down-regulate class 1 or
tumor cells that might reduce class 1
models is that we can have a regulation
of class 1 and an unabated activating
signal leading to NK cell activation
alternatively a cell may maintain class
1 expression but up regulate the
activation the number of activating
receptors leading to a dominant
activating signal and again leading to
NK cell activation now the reason I
introduced this framework is not to
provide me immunology 101 but because
there's actually an interesting
implication of this model and that is
the fact that for NK cells perhaps more
than any other cell type phenotype and
function a tightly linked because it's
this array of activating and inhibitory
receptors that allow it to send signals
and then transduce those signals to
control in case or activation so to
think about this another way this also
has very specific implications for how
we think of diversity and when we think
about diversity within lymphocytes we
typically think about for instance our B
cells that rearrange their ovdje to make
a wide range of antibody specificities
that could be specific for any virus
that we might encounter similarly R T
cells will arrange the vdg recombination
a t-cell receptor that's exclusively
specific for a peptide MHC complex but
in case those are different they're
really stuck with these germline encoded
activating and inhibitory receptors so
what does this mean for diversity and
really it's a different kind of
diversity in NK cells and in fact among
NK cells the way diversity I would argue
is generated is that the activating and
inhibitory receptors generate
combinatorial single cell phenotypes so
to draw this out a little further this
is really what we mean when we talk
about diversity is that there could be
one in case l that expresses a wide
range of these receptors another in K
cell that expresses a different array
and so forth now this is just of course
one definition of diversity but based on
this definition of diversity a few years
ago we discovered
we could define between 6,000 and 30,000
unique and K cell subsets in an
individual based on this idea of
genotypic diversity in addition we
identified because as receptors weren't
always the same in different people more
than 120,000 in ksl phenotypes in that
population and this captured a lot of
attention because it was a previously
unanticipated diversity of which durable
genetic environmental influences and I'm
not going to talk too much further about
that today but I'll turn you to the
paper records at the bottom if you're
interested in reading more about that
but it also raises an interesting
determination as to whether there could
be in case all subsets that are tuned to
be beneficial against certain pathogens
and as an infectious disease doctor this
is clearly something that I'm quite
interested in now another finding that's
been happening in parallel around the
same time is that it's been clearly and
definitively proven in mice and there's
strong suggestive data in humans as well
that in case else have memory like
features and this is an image from I
listened to on review in which we can
see that there's NK cell memory in Mouse
shown on the left side and humans on the
light and it's been shown to both
captains to viral antigens specifically
green c and b as well as to cytokine
stimulation and similar effects have
been shown in humans so the idea there
could be this vast diversity potentially
encoding some current specificity and
memory means that harnessing NK cells
could provide a new approach could be
broadly beneficial in pregnancy
infectious diseases and in cancer so
with this in mind this really begs a
question on how we should assess the
function of the natural killer cell
repertoire and first I'm going to tell a
brief story about fact that the stimulus
really matters in this case and this is
a study that was actually uh not
performed by mass cytometry but was a
study of influenza vaccination pregnant
women I have phone my laboratory
Alexander Kane and he was interested in
why pregnant women do so poorly with
influenza infection and have high rates
of vaccination so we chose to use
inactivated influenza vaccine
asian as really a model system is one of
the few times that you can control an
exposure to a virus so when you rolled a
cohort of 25 pregnant and 113 on
pregnant women who received inactivated
influenza vaccination and we drew blood
adizero private vaccination as well as a
day 7 and 28 to measure their immune
response and in the pregnant women also
six weeks postpartum within these women
we assess the in k + t-cell function and
just the basic gaiden scheme is shown
here in which we were able to identify
t-cells and NK cells and we work to add
in ksl function and t-cell function
based on the line of stimulation
conditions include shown here PA man on
my son as a positive control and when we
looked at both NK cells as well as cd4
and cd8 positive T cells will be
observed was similar to what have been
published in the past so in each case
the control women are shown in blue the
pregnant women are shown in shades of
grey and when i'm looking at day 0 on
the left and days is heaven on the right
and we observe that the pregnant women
have diminished NK cell responses when
we locate interfering gamma production
to both in sorry in both their NK cells
cd8 + cd4 t-cells both before and after
vaccination when the simulate to pay me
in on a lesson but it looks to do one
thing very differently from the prior
data that implies a pregnant woman have
suppressed immune responses and that was
that he actually looked at influenza
responses in vitro so he stimulated the
pbmc cultures with live influenza
vaccine which leads to Putin infection
of the monocytes within the culture so
what we can see is a mock infected
culture on the left in which there is
really no viral neuraminidase staining
and sixty-three percent of monocytes are
infected on the right and when we
perform this stimulation we observe that
these infected monocytes stimulate NK +
t-cell responses so on the right-hand
panel now we're looking at interferon
gamma production and we see six point
nine percent of the NK cells are
producing interferon gamma in response
to h1n1 whereas very little background
and came in on my sins famous
higher so now when we want to add the NK
cell influenza responses in pregnancy
this was where we got our first surprise
because what we saw was not a suppressed
immune response in pregnant women during
pregnancy but in fact a trend at day 0
and a significant difference at day 7
with pregnant women actually having
hyper inflammatory responses with more
higher frequency of NK cells producing
in apparel gamma when we looked at
nipple and beta production what we
observed was the same thing when we this
was actually hiring the pregnant women
both at baseline and post vaccination
and similarly CD 107 a production as a
marker of cytolysis was higher in the
pregnant women so this is really quite
surprising because it indicates that
pregnant women have enhanced not
suppressed immune responses but really
also tells us that the immuno deficiency
of pregnancy is dependent on the
stimulus when we look at nonspecific
stimulatory with peanut analyzing the
pregnant anymore suppressed but in this
case they have enhanced responses to the
relevant packaging of violence so just
to briefly summarize it short put the
increased in K and T so inflammatory
responses we made many amplified
pulmonary pathology and drive morbidity
from influence and pregnant women will
actually have a hyper inflammatory
responses antibody responses in this
cohort are maintained and in fact the
plasma blast induction might be higher
in the pregnant women but this really
makes a question as to why we see
enhanced immune responses in pregnancy
when the pregnancy has long been
associated is across only one immunity
and importantly here we looked at
through specific responses not responses
to cytokines or came in on my son
secondly we stimulate it in the context
of a total peripheral blood mononuclear
cell infection with monocytes T cells
these cells and dendritic cells all
present and able to communicate with one
another and in fact we recently
published the fact that the inflammatory
responses and monocytes and dendritic
cells is markedly elevated and pregnant
compared ml and pregnant women and most
of the data indicating that in K and T
cell responses are suppressed or done on
those cells in isolation not in the
context of this natural infection
so putting this together it's possible
bin immunomodulatory treatments in
conjunction with antivirals could
improve outcomes with severe influenza
but also an important for the data in
present max is Jenna also highlight the
importance of using physiologically
relevant stimuli and also togas
infections so that we don't have to
worry about MHC class 1 reactions
causing false positives when we're
thinking about NK cell responses so next
I wanted to really turn back in thinking
about the stimulus but now also thinking
about what I told you about earlier the
NK cell diversity and specifically what
is the link between in ksl diversity and
function does it even matter Antunes
first we wanted to understand how stable
this NK cell diversity was and try to
gain better insight into what the
controlling factors were so we first
performed a very simple study which was
that we talked to 12 people into giving
us our blood each week for five minutes
and then again six months later and
using math cytometry site off we broadly
profile there in case of repertoire over
the six-month period to determine how
stable it was and dr. poon already
introduced this but the workflow from
site off experiments were very similar
to a conventional flow cytometry
experiment in that we labeled our
antibodies now in this case with
elemental isotopes we pass them into the
set off machine which has the nebulizer
than the inductively coupled plasma
chamber into the quadrupole to renew of
the row wait ions and then through the
time-of-flight mass spectrometer at
which point the signals are integrated
I'm going to save our flow junk files in
this case this was the perfect function
to look at in Hazel's because it allows
us to look at more than 40 analytes for
trillions of marker combinations and
this is important because they're at
least 20 to 30 and K cell receptors we
were interested in evaluating in
addition there's only no need for
compensation because of the more overlap
so to look at this a graduate soon my
mascara straße lb first developed and in
case of gating scheme which is actually
fairly extensive in which we identified
ourselves based on DNA truck lighters we
gave it out the beads to be as formal SS
then doing a live silicate
and then did a series of negative gates
to avoid ESL's based on cd19 stating t
cells based on cd3 monocytes based on a
series of gates to get rid of cd33
positive cells as well as cd56 negative
hla-dr positive cells finally on what
would be one or I el titulo cells before
finally getting ourselves within our in
case I'll gate at this point we then
performed for many of these analyses
boolean gating analyses so the boolean
gate analyses just at this point we
chose each marker and determine the
level at which we thought it was
positive or negative an example of many
of our gates and our representative
stains are shown here and this allows us
to look at each combination of receptors
expressed by the NK cell so when we
apply this theory to look at the NK cell
repertoire what we found was that the NK
cell repertoire stable for six months in
the individual and this is just a
visualization to try to capture that in
a very large scale but I recognize it's
very busy what we're looking at here is
that each column with a number of all
that represents one individual with each
dot the expression level of each marker
coded by the size of the dot indicating
the frequency of that marker being
expressed on and k cells I need each
individual those that are shaded in
darker or seen be sort of positive
individuals and those are shade shaded
in lighter stainer seen be- individuals
the type of marker or showing the color
and really it's probably helpful if i'm
going to set up and what we can see is
that each dot represents the frequency
so if we look at this marker and KP 30
what we observe is that expression
levels actually quite stable between 61
and 63 percent at each of these time
points spanning across six months in an
individual and we observe a similar
pattern where some markers are expressed
in some individuals somewhat those are
expressed in others but overall within
an individual these dots are about the
same size indicating relative stability
this is obviously a very qualitative way
to look at this data so we really wanted
to be able to evaluate it quantitatively
and to do this what we calculated was
the ninety-five percent credible
interval for the mean standard GV
shin of each receptor so this is
essentially the standard deviation of
the standard deviations of each receptor
expression profile across all these
individuals for a six-month period and
when we did this what we observe was a
range in these markers between the
individuals but relatively low numbers
as you can see here between zero and
point one with some markers that are
expressed mostly at lower levels being
even lower than others but unfortunately
this is somewhat of a unitless measure
as is obvious because it's generation of
standard deviations so to put this in
perspective what we did was we took some
natural killer cells and we clinch heard
them for three days in the presence of
other aisle to be shown the purple dogs
royal 15 showing mikuni dots what we
observe is that over three days in vitro
we observe up to eight fold more change
in these receptor expression patterns
and we observe over six months in an
individual and keep in mind that at 9k
cells estimated to live only about 14
days in vivo so this implies there's
some sort of homeostatic mechanism
maintaining the same k cell repertoire
and yet they're highly susceptible to
modulation and in just an example this
is shown here where that same marker and
KP 30 is shown both in the unstimulated
condition and after three days of either
il-15 or il-2 so from this we really
conclude that the repertoire is stable
but highly sensitive to modification
which raises the idea that it could be
also sensitive to optimization and in
fact when we did the same calculation we
looked at function and we observe that
the function was similarly stable in
these individuals over time now the
problem with what I've explained before
is that's really not taking advantage of
this blog mass spectrometry data in
which we're able to look not just at the
individual receptors but also the
combinatorial phenotypes but when we're
talking about the combinatorial
phenotypes with 28 and hazel receptors
we're talking about billions of
different quantum subpopulations so in
order to come up with a better way to
quantify this we decided to borrow from
ecology and use the inverse simpson
index and this allows us to quantify the
NK cell repertoire because
colleges have spent a lot of time
thinking about how for instance you can
deal with understand porn so which is
essentially what we're doing every time
we do in flow cytometry experiment will
grab about 10,000 cells we try to
extrapolate into what is happening in
that individual that's very similar to
going out into the forest and counting
bears if you go out into the forest and
you count bearers and you find all black
bears then there's going to be a
relatively homogeneous population in a
very low inverse sensitive index on the
other hand if you count the Bears and
you find a few other bear species mixed
in it's still going to be alone inver
Simpson index because one species is
dominating this but there are several
other species as well whereas an evenly
distributed population is going to have
a very high inverse Simpson index so
what we did was we called each and cane
cell phenotype based on these receptor
expression patterns we determined by
site offices species equivalent to a
bear and we use this Simpson index which
mathematically is inverse sum of the
squares of the relative abundances of
each species to calculate this diversity
and when they looked at this what we
intriguingly found was that adults have
a set point diversity so if we look in
our same 12 individuals we observe
fairly tight clustering of each of these
individuals diversity but what was
intriguing was that some people had
relatively low diversity such as
individual number one well some people
had fairly high diversity such as
individual number as well number two and
there were some exceptions such as
individual number ten who has sent
abroad overage but in general when we
model this akin to what we did before it
was a very tight range less than point
one as before so this will allow us to
question what is causing this diversity
and what we needed training found was
that the in case of diversity correlates
with the differentiation stratus and we
are demonstrating this here by looking
at the correlation between diversity on
the x axis and CD 57 expression on the y
axis the CD 57 is really a marker of an
experienced or NK cell that is already
going through some sort of
differentiation and we observe a strong
positive correlation between these
similarly we observe a negative
correlation between diversity and kg GMA
generally consider a marker of immature
in case
to drive this point further we wanted to
look in cord blood to see if this one
hold true and in fact when we looked in
cord blood as expected boobs are
relatively low expression of CD 57 shown
in green whereas adults have a broad
range shown in purple and similarly cord
blood cells in green have higher nkg to
a expression and when we looked at the
diversity of cord bloods in keith at the
NK cells that expressed CD 57 sorry
we're having a slit connection issue but
i think i'm back online when we look at
the NK cell populations that expressed
NK GTA so these are the NK cells that
are relatively more immature than
individuals what we observed was that
many of these phenotypes will share
between different individuals in other
words my NK cells look very much like my
neighbors and everyone else's those that
are immature however the NK cells
express CD 57 those have already
differentiated in response to some sort
of exposure and vile infection are
relatively more unique and in fact it's
very few of them are shared among all 12
individuals so this tells us that more
unique and more diverse and case'll
repertoire is a development experience
so with this framework in mind we really
wanted to now understand what
implications this diversity and this
immuno immune experience has for the NK
cell response to HIV and to do this we
really needed to go back to what I was
talking about earlier in terms of
finding the right system to study on ksl
responses so what we did was we
developed a set off panel that allowed
us to capture as many activating
receptors as we College shown in blue as
well as a number of functional receptors
also show me blue the inhibitory
receptor is it basically tell me in case
on the back off as well as a number of
media markers and we need an assistant
to really catch in key cells in the act
of responding to hiv-infected cells so
to do this we adapted systems that were
developed to look at the ability of cd8
positive T cells to suppress HIV
replication and we simply used natural
killer cells what we had shown was that
in vitro natural killer cells could
suppress infection
with of HIV in autologous cd4 positive T
cells in fact there's a range in the
ability of individual donors to do this
so now we had a system in which we could
study the NK cell response as well as a
sigh top panel that would allow us to
look in great detail out which NK cells
a capable of meeting miss response and
this is where the story gets even more
confusing because no matter how we want
we could find absolutely no predictive
features that distinguish NK cells that
could respond to hiv-infected cells and
this is not the case for all viruses but
it certainly was for HIV but this one
was to think about what could be
determining which in k cells are
responding and what we noted was when we
turn back to this idea of
differentiation was it the
differentiated and k cells were actually
qualitatively and quantitatively
different in the type of response
unmediated so when we want to add the
city 57 positive in case L shown in pink
in the city 57 negative in case I'll
shown in blue what we noted was that
during the response to HIV experience
City 57 positive NK cells were
significantly more likely to secrete
interferon gamma or tnf but they were
less likely to kill and they were also
somewhat less likely to proliferate is a
trend for deep roots proliferation so
this implies that differentiated in k
cells favor of cytokine production at
the cost of cytotoxicity and
proliferation but this still doesn't
really tell us what is happening to the
in case of leopard Warren why we weren't
able to determine what is different
about those in from gamma or those
killing or those TMF secreting NK cells
so we begin to look more broadly what
happened to the overall NK cell
population during the antiviral response
and to do this when i'm showing here is
a principle coordinate analysis this is
like a principal component analysis for
those who are familiar with that in that
it's a way to reduce the dimensionality
of the data and look in two dimensions
at those components that account for the
most diversity so this is the projection
of more than 11,000 boo name phenotypes
going to 12 donors we looked at in which
case each dot represents a unique
cleaner to connect of NK cells plotted
against component
too and as we expected we see this broad
range and this diversity between these
individuals because we already know that
in case else are diverse but what's
intriguing is what happens when we now
expose this NK cell population
hiv-infected t-cells and although this
is very hard to explain in a 2d
dimension what more require now is a
third component showing color in no
blood to blue color coding required to
explore the same amount of diversity
what is I hope you can appreciate its
really an expansion in this cloud of it
natural killer cells and in fact you can
quantify this by calculating the center
of the centroid of this cloud of cells
and we can calculate the sum of the
squared distances from the centroid to
each individual point before and after
exposure to HIV and what we observe is a
significant increase in the diversity of
the incase of population during the
response to HIV so wilderness tells us
that recognition of hiv-infected cells
causes NK cells to diversify this
potential explains why we're unable to
find a unique phenotype because there's
just so many more phenotypes our signal
to noise ratio is not there we next
wondered whether this is a general
feature of antiviral responses and in
fact if we look at responses to West
Nile virus infection both before and
after we observe the same thing miss
expansion in the cloud of NK cells
responding to us an infection so and in
fact we can calculate this in multiple
ways if I turn back now to that inverse
Simpson index and we look at the
diversity before and after exposure to
HIV infected T cells or West Nile virus
infected in cells we observe a similar
significant increase in NK cell
diversity during a short term in vitro
and about response so this really next
led us to the question of how in case of
diversity might influence the risk of
HIV acquisition and the move NK cells in
HIV infection is quite interesting and
that they're strongly implicated in
pathogenesis of disease progression
however the role of NK cells in nature
the active acquisition has been argued
both lanes there's some pretty strong
data indicating that intrinsic and
Castle activity may be protect
and this is from an old paper from
Daniel scotto jira what we're looking at
is the specific lysis of natural killer
cells and a k562 killing assay from
under EU exposed uninfected individuals
and observe that these individuals who
are highly exposed to HIV d yet resist
infection have much higher rates of in
Hazel activity then do the controls in C
or seropositive people who are treated
and untreated showing other markers and
along similar lines more recently in the
caprice a cohort it was nicely shown
that the frequency of NK cells producing
interferon gamma in response to a
Tongass hiv-infected cd4 t-cells was
also higher in the controls women who
did not go on to acquire HIV infection
in this trial now intriguingly
generalized NK cell activation is also
associated with increased risk rate of
infection and in fact within the same
caprice of cohort if they quantified the
frequency of NK cells expressing hla-dr
as an activation marker the women who
went on to become HIV infected the cases
had significantly higher in case or
active activity than did the controls so
with this framework in mind we wanted to
study what the invivo consequences of NK
cell diversity were and we were
fortunate and that we had access to
samples from the moma salomaa study this
was a study that was aimed to identify
the predictors of HIV acquisition during
and after pregnancy in which we enrolled
1304 HIV negative pregnant women in
rural western kenya this was a
collaborative effort of john canoe kia
in camry the Kenyan Medical Research
Institute as long as Alison Drake and
Chris Sean Stewart at the University of
Washington the incidence of HIV
acquisition in this cohort was 2.3 one
per hundred person hears and within this
sample we were fortunate in that we had
access to singles from 13 cases these
are women who went on to acquire HIV
infection as well as 23 controls these
were women who were matched for risk
factors for HIV acquisition and very
importantly we had peripheral blood
mononuclear cells from match time points
grade infection and I stress this point
because these are honking women who do
not already have HIV but
or trying to do is predict who is going
to go on to acquire HIV based on their
phenotype we were fortunate because
we've been doing research in Kenya for
many many years and we knew the criteria
and the risk factors for HIV acquisition
Botha miss kill wood and other similar
cohorts over the last 20 years and thus
we were able to match our controls from
among the 1,300 for women based on age
knowledge of partners receipt of an HIV
test marital status in history of
trading sex for money or goods and we
also observed no significant differences
in the reign of sexually transmitted
infections or the reporting of
unprotected sex between our cases and
controls so within these we of course
did what we did which was we perform
site off to look at whether we could
find any markers that could predict
whisking HIV acquisition and importantly
we look not just at the natural killer
cells but using our site off panel at
the cd4 and cd8 t-cells as well and this
I recognize is an incredibly busy slide
but what we're looking at is the
frequency of each marker expression the
mothers are shown along the bottom and
the cases in blue and the controller
sorry the cases in red and the controls
in blue and it's small because there's
really nothing interesting here in fact
that even controlling for multiple
comparisons there was no see no marker
that could predict the risk of the HIV
acquisition this includes the
generalized immune activation status of
t-cells which has been associated with
disease progression and thought to
perhaps contribute to risk but in this
particular study it did not do so
however we've got a surprise when we
went back to our inverse Simpson index
and we quantified the NK cell diversity
and what we found was that there was a
significant increase in in case L
diversity among the women who went on to
acquire HIV infection and that's just
good here you can see the shift in the
curve and in fact we can qualify this
risk obviously their significant overlap
but nonetheless based on a logistic
regression the odds ratio for HIV
acquisition were 2.5 for every 100 point
increase in diversity so just to put
this in perspective what we're observing
here is an approximately 500 point range
scale sorry range in the scale that case
I'll diversity and for every 100 points
on that
we increase the risk of acquiring HIV is
2.5 fold higher the risk of acquiring
HIV associated with for instance is all
sort of sexually transmitted infections
such as syphilis is about three to four
fold so this is actually quite a
substantial risk in addition the risk of
the reduced risk in male circumcisions
similarly about 2 to 3 fold both
treatment of syndromic STDs as well as
circumcision will thought to be
significant enough risk to launch
multiple randomized control trials to
try and prevent HIV acquisition in fact
it was also only the diversity of the
adhesive receptors that predicted HIV
acquisition in this study so really to
put this together what we've noonish
built with our high profile analysis is
a model of NK cell diversity and this is
leah model that requires testing but I
put this forward to drive for the
research and what we believe is
happening is that there's we all start
out with a naive baseline and queso
repertoire that's actually relatively
homogeneous and as we go through life
will expose two different viruses in
each of these viral exposures leads to
diversification and specialization of
the in case of repertoire in each
subsequent exposures going to further
diversify and specialized that
repertoire but what's intriguing to
think is that this might have its limits
and what we don't know is just this
diversification and specialization lead
to a decreased ability to respond to a
de novo pathogen now importantly this
does not eliminate the possibility of NK
cell memory because while we might be
blessed good at responding to the read
virus after seeing the purple and the
green we might be in fact better at
responding to the green virus the next
time we encounter so to bring this to a
conclusion what I hope I've convinced
you of is that the human natural killer
cell repertoire is astoundingly diverse
the diverse and case on record waters
are associated with terminal
differentiation and cytokine production
perhaps at the cost of showing activity
and proliferation the short-term
exposure to virus-infected cells
augments and kcl diversity and that in a
cohort of Kenyan women NK cell diversity
predicts the risk of HIV acquisition but
of course confirmatory cohorts are
needed this was a very
studying efforts are ongoing in that
regard but what's intriguing to think
about is that this tells us that in
kiesel diversity may in fact not be
beneficial to the innate immune system
this is a somewhat heretical thought
given that we always think of diversity
is such a great thing in the immune
system but of course it's important to
note that it could just be a correlative
risk that there could be some unmeasured
factor that's correlating with the in
case of diversity and that factors
actually what's driving this association
interestingly enough regardless of
whether the in case of diversity is
equivalent or is actually playing a
causative role in this increased risk
assessing the prior experience of the
innate immune system could have both
functional and clinical utility in
predicting the vigor of its response so
to find the end I just want to
acknowledge the tremendous efforts of my
lab pictured here in a particular gara
stress LD who was a graduate student who
had all the HIV studies as won't work
closely with Ruth Montgomery neyo Yale
on the West Nile studies as well as a
number of other investigators in my lab
Olivia happy who has worked on BBB and
some work I didn't have the chance to
describe lisa krone staff working on
influenza as well as alex kay and we
meung and nicholas balances work on each
one's a very pregnancy we initially
develop the site off panels in
collaboration with peter peril and amir
forwards at stanford and had significant
health from your own lab and the davis
lab as well as holden maker and michael
i polled at the hom see and we're
indented to our amazing statisticians is
in the homes injury of qiyamah both
helped us deal with this highly complex
data thank you very much thank you very
much
Kathryn for that exciting and
informative presentation at this point
we're going to move into the
question-and-answer session some of
these seminar so um you can submit
questions and answers by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window type in your
question in the box that appears on the
screen and then click send and we're
going to try to answer as many of your
questions as we can within the time
allotted so just to begin there were a
few questions that I'll begin with based
on my short portion of the talk the
first one was did you say heterogeneity
at the single-cell level just to clarify
what my meaning was while talking in the
first couple of slides is that I because
of the complexity of biological systems
we need to be able to address that
heterogeneity mass cytometry enables you
to do that by being able to look at very
high dimensional panels which allows you
to analyze both the breadth of cell
types in your system of interest as well
as their a depth of function and this is
gained by being able to look at many
many markers simultaneously and get that
data at the single-cell level the second
question was can we identify the
population based on the cell dividing
status at the single-cell level and
Katherine may also want to discuss this
but we do from fluidigm have reagents
that allow you to address a cell cycle
we have io todai oxy being to be able to
look at S phase and then by utilizing
antibodies against certain cell cycle
phase specific markers were able to
assess all ranges of all phases of the
cell cycle um the next question um will
be for Katherine I'm n
the question is could you address a bit
more on why pregnant women with
increased NK response have a poor have
poor cellular immunity is is this um
meaning that pregnancy is bad for cancer
treatment okay I'm going to take that
over um well there are a few things to
keep in mind my point was was really not
that pregnancy is neither good nor bad
and that it's a complex state and it
depends on what specific function you're
looking at and I think there's there's a
misunderstanding in a massive
oversimplification that gets repeated
over and over the pregnancy represents
an immunodeficiency state and that makes
some logical sense because pregnant
women have to tolerate their semi
allergenic fetus but I think it's
important to keep in mind that not all
arms of the immune system are
necessarily suppressed or not all
responses are suppressed and in fact
there is depressed cellular immune
responses if you look at a number of
different factors including cytokine
stimulation and as I said responses in
isolation but in fact the innate immune
system is activated potentially to make
out for some of that suppression and
it's been well described that their
increased regulatory t-cells and a
number of other factors going on during
pregnancy in terms of the setting of
cancer treatment during pregnancy that
is whole ball of wax which is is
honestly difficult to address because
most of the agencies to treat cancer are
potentially harmful to the fetus so it
really is on a case-by-case basis
whether any immunomodulatory treatment
of cancer is going to happen to my
knowledge there's no data indicating
that pregnant women are more likely to
develop cancer during pregnancy based on
this depressed cellular some aspects of
cellular immunity being suppressed
during pregnancy
I guess the final point about that is
it's important to note that that many
autoimmune diseases get better during
pregnancy based on the types of immune
responses that are suppressed though
that's not universally the case there
are a few such as lupus typically
antibody associate diseases that can
actually undergo flares during pregnancy
but the vast majority improves
significantly during pregnancy thank you
dr. blush the next question is also for
you um the question is to in two parts
but when investigating diversity a how
do you and is it relevant to distinguish
functional versus lineage defining
markers and be you subset this data set
to track specific subgroups over time
okay just waiting to get so the first
part of that question was how do we
distinguish diversity in that that is a
very good question I didn't go into
great detail on that fur and it really
depends on what the question is for most
of the data i just presented we refer to
phenotypic diversity in terms of the
array of activating and inhibitory
receptors and our interest was whether
if we looked at functional cells or
non-functional cells there were any
particular patterns of these receptors
on them so in that case we would looking
just at the phenotypic markers in terms
of diversities you'll end up with a
different level if you look at
functional diversity as well and in fact
we analyze the data both ways and and
many other ways that could take another
several hours if not days to describe
but there's a huge amount of functional
and phenotypic diversity it's also
important to note that that we do see a
both heterogeneity in terms of phenotype
and function but it's so great an HIV
unlike many other viruses that were
unable to distinguish specific
phenotypes
in terms of specific sub setting and
following up the individuals I'm not
sure I fully understand the question but
our goal was to identify specific and K
cell subsets that we thought were
particularly responsive to a given virus
and then of course be able to sort them
and discover whether those were in fact
uniquely able to respond and in fact in
HIV since we weren't able to identify a
phenotypic subset we were unable to do
that in terms of looking at our cohorts
and looking at specific outcomes within
the cohorts unfortunately these are too
small at cohorts we simply don't have
the power statistically to do any
further subsetting but we're looking to
acquire additional cohorts and answer
some of these same questions in a
confirmatory independent cohort which is
actually much more statistically robust
the next question is also for dr. blish
did you study HLA subtypes to stratify
NK cell diversity and response to
infection this HLA diversity impact the
NK cell repertoire diversity
great that's that's an excellent
question so we did HLA subtype everyone
again these were fairly small studies so
our power was was fairly limited but if
me I turned people to the first 2013
paper we describe it that we were
actually surprised that we did not see
an obvious significant association
between the NK cell repertoire and the
HOA subtypes in terms of education in
other words we didn't see a significant
imprint phenotypic imprint of Education
on the NK cell repertoire within the
African cohorts frankly the HOA
diversity is so great that within a
cohort of about thirty six people we
were really unable to subset again based
on different HLA types to see if there
was a specific association with disease
risk but overall it appears as though
the in case of repertoire is formed
somewhat genetically in terms of the
array of care and K GTA and laura b 0 1
with an overlying diversity of the
activating receptors but that the impact
of that the HLA educating those cells
through here or HOA e or sorry NK g 2 a
is not noted in the diversity as we
measure at phenotypically but that may
require just hundreds and hundreds more
the next question is also for dr. blish
when you divine a subset in a boolean
way do you include functional markers
again that the question was about
bullying dating again that depends on
what question were asking we in fact
looked both at you know median
expression and at boolean gating in
terms of determining the frequency of
functional and k cells but we did not
define our diversity based on functional
markers in this setting though it if we
did it didn't really change any of our
overall conclusions we analyzed it into
both ways but I did not present that
data next question for dr. blish what
maintains the repertoire diversity
within a person and how come newly
developed NK cells are not more
homogeneous bone marrow transplants does
stroma micro environment affect
person-specific diversity okay there
were about three questions in there and
I'm hoping that I got them all um so the
first is what maintains the NK cell
receptor diversity and and I presume
that means in adults and the the short
answer is we honestly have no idea but
it's an active area of investigation the
the long answer is that we have some
hints and those hands come from both our
work and importantly many other
investigators so first of all and bring
to that there is relative homogeneity of
the developing and key cells but there's
also a very regulated pathway of NK cell
development typically they express nkg
to a first then a subset depending on
the HOA haplotype will down-regulate and
k GQ and upregulate an array of tears
and that has a huge impact on the
diversity and the extent to which that's
it
fluence by the bone marrow stroma is not
known but it is known that education
through HLA molecules have a significant
impact on that in terms of once the NK
cells gone through that developmental
pathway and it's either an NK gqa or
cure or even a no Express in case L how
that diversity is maintained remains
unknown but there's definitely hands
that there could be some epigenetic
modification and this comes primarily
from work looking at CMV infection which
causes an imprinting on the record warm
and the NK g to see expressing NK cells
have a significant epigenetic imprint
that may play a role in their diversity
and I see we're going to go in time so
I'm gonna stop there thank you we have
time for a few more questions um the
next one is again for dr. blish can you
comment about the potential NK memory
subsets do you think these can be found
in hiv-infected individuals so I I
started this project hoping that we
could find NK memories subsets in
hiv-infected individuals and I mean the
truthful answer is is I don't know that
said it's there's very strong evidence
that the NK gtc CD 57 positive NK cells
are CMV memory like cells and we can
argue all day over what you call a
memory cell vs not but in addition I'd
point folks to Keith Reeves work in the
macaque system in which they've
identified in Kate memory cells for SIV
and so I think it's not impossible but I
think that it's there there are really
two possibilities one is that we have
HIV has come on the human population so
recently that honestly the NK cell
response has not evolved a memory
population to deal with a virus like HIV
and the other is that we just need to
keep searching and it's more subtle
and so efforts on going
right on the next question for dr. blish
do you suspect that NK cells become
exhausted due to ongoing exposure to
virus it's a very good question um and
me I suspect yes but I'm not sure if
it's going to be in the same way that
the T cells become exhausted and that's
something we'll explore certainly there
are subset of NK cells that express
markers such as pd1 in addition there's
a lot of really exciting data from other
groups about pigeon regulating and K
cell functions so I think it's not
impossible to think that NK cells could
undergo a similar degree of exhaustion
and then in fact some of those
immunomodulatory drugs like PDL one and
so forth could be acting on NK cells as
well as T cells we're almost out of time
so this will be the last question um for
dr. blecch do you have a model as to how
the NK cell population would accumulate
diversity over time and experience so
question was do I have a model as to how
the NK cell population would would
accumulate diversity and I don't have a
model beyond what I displayed but what
we do find is that the exposure to
during an acute response to a virus at
least in vitro we observe an increase in
diversity and presumably for this model
to hold some of that diversity would be
maintained and that we would see similar
effects in vivo we do not have the in
vivo data yet to prove that so it is
just a model but one we're actively
exploring thank you very much dr. blish
um I'd like to thank everyone who has
attended the session today and for your
thoughtful questions and participation
I'd let also like to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through March 28th
of 2017 and you will receive an email
from lab roots letting you know when
this webcast will be available feel free
to share this amount so that's all for
now thank you very much for joining us
and we hope to see you at future laborat
sessions goodbye